il nous faut aussi diminuer le nombre de
violences et de blessés lors des
manifestations
qu'il s'agisse de ceux qui touchent les
forces de l'ordre où les citoyens qui
sont là cette attente est forte
c'est pourquoi sans mettre en danger en
aucune manière les forces de l'ordre
sans les priver de leurs moyens de
l'exercice de leurs missions difficiles
et de leur protection légitime la
doctrine ou les conditions d'emploi de
certains matériels vont évoluer
je pense notamment à l'usagé lbd qui
sera dès demain
encadré obligatoirement assorti d'un
superviseur pour mieux évaluer la
situation d'ensemble est désigné
l'objectif je pense également à
l'utilisation des grenades gmd qui sera
retirée du service suivant les
recommandations du dgpn et du dggn et
remplacé dès demain par un nouveau
modèle offrant moins de projection
auteurs en effet dès ce samedi